i think all of the prisons we have now
in britain are failing us
because they are just universities of
crime they come out with no skills they
live in this alien environment behind
these massive walls with barbed wire and
you treat them like animals we
cage people in prisons as if they were
wild animals and
unsurprisingly when they come out they
behave in many cases like animals if you
treat someone like an animal they behave
like one if you call someone a criminal
and you constantly
say that they're a bad person don't be
surprised when they come out and do more
bad things because that's what happens
when you treat people like that
i'm joined by chris dawg chris welcome
to the show
thanks chris good to meet you pleasure
to have you here what's
what's qc stand for so
qc stands for queen's council so one of
her majesty's
council which is a special kind of
barrister lawyer
and we're appointed to kind of basically
be the league of the elite when it comes
to
being being a lawyer basically and even
though i say so myself which i do
are you the sas of the uh we are they
they bring us
in when it gets messy you're the the wet
work black squad scent in under the
cover of darkness you've got it we're
the navy seals you've got to go
underwater you've got to like get
through mud it's yeah it's
it's uh basically anyone who's in the
proper proper [ __ ]
we're the ones who are supposed to take
them out
the deepest kind the smelliest kind i
love it
i absolutely love it okay so justice is
on trial today
i want you to give the opening speech
approach the microphone please crystal
qc and give us the opening speech
why is justice on trial well i'm i'm
putting justice on track because i've
spent 26 years as a criminal lawyer
and in all of that time i think most of
what i've done has been a complete waste
of
a waste of time and waste of my life
because the criminal justice system
that's the
police the prosecution of people locking
people up in prison
chasing after people because they take
drugs all it does
is make society worse lock people up
they just go back in again they commit
more crime when they come out and then
it costs us a load of money when they
when when they're in there 50 000 a year
to keep someone in prison
we're locking up young kids and some
kids as young as 10
are going into the criminal courts which
is completely insane
and of course we continue to prosecute
people for drug crime
when as i say in my book drugs have been
taken for tens of millions of years by
human beings and no one's gonna we're
not gonna stop people
you can't you can't you can't change
people's basic desire
to get wasted and that's gonna happen it
happens today it happened a thousand
years ago it happened fifty 000 years
ago
so as long as we keep trying to
stop people doing things that like that
they want to do that largely don't harm
anyone else we're going to just keep on
making the same old mistakes and we kill
people with overdoses and gang wars and
knife crime and stabbings
and i'm just sick of it and i i and the
time has come for someone in my position
you know fairly kind of senior position
in the profession to say do you know
what why are we doing it what's the
point
and and that's what the book's all about
what's the point of it and i don't think
there is to most of it i think we need
to change it all start again
what do we need to know before we can
get into this is there some background
that we have to kind of
lay get the lay of the land about why
crime and punishment's even important
well it's in the book uh interestingly
so you don't need to know anything
before you read the book because as you
know i
i go right the way back to 28 million
years ago when cannabis evolved on the
plains of the you know of
of china um and people started using
cannabis in uh
in funeral rituals so they could all get
wasted to you know to
kind of get over the grief of losing
their loved ones and uh
you know and and i go into all of like
why we got here you know that
what prisons were like going back 10 000
years ago what they were like in the
victorian era
you know when kids were hanged at the
age of eight you know for stealing
apples you know
or it's all in the book and and but most
of all i hope what you agree in the book
is
it's just some real life story some sort
of you know there's some tragic ones
about people who
die in tragic circumstances you know
drug dealers getting murdered
and and and for what and and and the
point the answer your question is i
don't think i think anybody that is a
human being
and has ever either been the victim of
crime has known someone who is or has
maybe committed a crime or takes drugs
or knows someone who does
anyone who's interested in crime justice
punishment
will be interested in what's in the book
my mum
is a crown court usher okay i know many
many of them they're the most important
people in the room
the ones that keep the wheels oiled and
they absolutely do
and you know what i i had what's called
a pupil barrister that's like a trainee
that was training under me a few years
ago
and he asked me a month or so after i
started
you know training him he said come on
chris give me the pearls of wisdom
what's the most important thing i said
keep the ushers happy
mom keep the others are you listening i
hope so because i tell you what if you
keep the ushers happy
that and all and i always have done you
know you you you you treat them with
respect and what happens is that when
you need to get your case on because
you're desperate to go somewhere else
yeah
i'll make sure we get your case on next
and i bet your mum's one of the nice
ones chris yeah she is
she is an absolute star yeah absolutely
above and beyond the call of duty she's
the
uh wetwork black ops equivalent i think
for the ushers they send her
yeah when there's red wine everywhere
from a from an exhibit or whatever
whatever the hell needs to be sorted out
um so okay let's go hey chris on the red
wine subject right so here's a story for
you
um talking about that and here and the
story and it relates to ushers
many years ago uh a uh uh a a kiss he
was in his sort of
six days a very rotund kind of red-faced
kind of barrister of the old model
and and he insisted we went out and
drunk a load of red wine at lunchtime in
the middle of a murder trial
and the judge was sent the usher to find
us in the pub and he said
oh no no i'm not coming back to court
today i'll come back tomorrow
and they actually had to take the
message back to the high court judge
that this particular qc wasn't wasn't
for doing the afternoon session
how did that go down well it was 20
years ago and 20 years ago you know the
qcs can get away with stuff like that
i'm not going to try it now though it
wouldn't work now
prison talk to me about prison what do
you know about prison
prison well i've traveled all over the
world i've been to probably
hundreds of prisons certainly dozens and
dozens of them in my career because i
have to visit clients there
but i also spent a lot of last year
researching the book and i traveled to
you know the deep south of america and
alabama and saw some of the
sort of hell holes of prison there and i
looked into the very different kinds of
prisons that they have in places like
norway and
and they're more sort of progressive
kind of scandinavian countries
and my kind of take on prisons and as
you know there's a chapter in the book
and it's called why we should close all
the prisons
because i think all of the prisons we
have now in britain are failing us
because they are just universities of
crime
that people go in and i tell the story
of a young man who went into prison
never taken a drug in his life and came
out a heroin addict
now what what what are we doing when
prison you can get heroin in prison get
any drugs in prison
um and and you could you they come out
with no skills they live in this alien
environment behind these massive walls
with barbed wire
and you treat them like animals we we ca
we cage people
in prisons as if they were wild animals
and unsurprisingly when they come out
they behave
in many cases like animals and and
if you treat someone like an animal they
behave like one if you call someone a
criminal
and you constantly say that they're a
bad person
don't be surprised when they come out
and do more bad things because that's
what happens when you treat people like
that
so my my kind of whole philosophy and
that comes across in the book is
knock them all down all of these big
victorian prisons with the cell blocks
and the heavy gates and the big heavy
cell doors and the bars
knock them down turn them into shopping
centers or apartments and start again
and do something completely different
because at the moment we just got a
prison population that goes up and up
we've got more and more people who are
being locked up for longer and longer
than ever before
and yet we have got crime on the streets
we've got murders we've got stabbings
and we've got
shootings the public don't feel safe so
if we carry on like this we will end up
like the americans with 2.3 million plus
people in prison in the states and
off the chart levels of violent and
serious crime
and that's the that's that's the problem
with prison it just doesn't work it does
the opposite
of what we want it to do we want to send
people to prison so they come out and
don't commit another crime but what
happens is they come out and they commit
loads
of war crimes so why why do you why does
that happen
it happens because prisons condition
people to be
criminals if you if you you know if you
send someone to tennis camp
and they play tennis all day they're
gonna get quite good at tennis
now if you send someone to prison and
they hang out with criminals all day
and they learn about crime they're gonna
come out and they're quite good at crime
but they're not gonna be any use to
anything else i mean your tennis guy
isn't gonna be any use of plumbing
because all he's learned is tennis and
in prison all they learn is crime
they don't know anything else there's
virtually no rehabilitation many of them
have got serious mental health problems
serious psychiatric conditions or or
enormous emotional problems i mean one
of the things that really
absolutely drive me mad is the fact that
the prisons consist of many
many people who were in the care system
as kids
so you're 15 times more likely to go to
prison
if you were in care as a child now what
that means is
that we're locking up people who are who
have been in the care of the state for
most of their childhood
and they are damaged people and we need
to care for them and by caring for them
it's not just to be soft the reason
outside of prison
is because you want to normalize them
and make them feel part of society so
they can live like the rest of us
but what we do is we send them instead
of tennis camp we send them to
worse criminals than than they were when
they went in if they're lucky because
many of them in there are self-harming
committed suicide
it's an absolutely animalistic and
archaic institution the way that we run
our prisons in this country and they've
just got to be shut down
because otherwise we're just going to
keep he's going to go up and up and
we're going to have more and more
serious and violent crime
[Music]
what's the purpose or what should be the
purpose of prisons i i
don't we need to be kept safe from all
of the all of the crims aren't there
people dangerous people that need to be
kept
away from the general public there are
and there's a very small number
actually because uh i mentioned in the
book there that 69
of people in prison are in there for a
non-violent crime
they're in there for a drug offense or
or a fraud offense or some sort of theft
defense
uh and and only a 31 are in there for a
violent crime and many of them
are fairly low level and trivial
assaults but when it comes to you're
right there are psychotics there are
people who are
seriously violent and dangerous and
maybe they amount to 10 or 15
of the total prison population and yes
we need to be kept safe from them
but 99.9 of them even the most violent
ones
even the murderers will one day come out
of prison
there's only about 60 in the entire 80
odd thousand in prison
who will never be released almost every
prisoner will one day be released
so you have to still think yourself okay
you might have committed a murder
but why are we focusing on hammering you
punishing you
keeping you in terrible conditions uh on
during your sentence why are we not
focusing on the day you come out
because it's the day you come out that
matters the day you come out
it determines whether you're going to go
and get a job whether you're going to be
able to keep
and reconnect with your family whether
you're going to be able to pay rent or a
mortgage and have somewhere to live
and at the moment many people come out
of prison with nothing
except the skills they've learned in
crime camp while they've been in there
they're damaged individuals they've got
no connection with their family got no
job nowhere to live
and if you if you do that people are
going to just go straight back on the
streets
and they're going to go straight back to
crime so that's the reason we
you know we are we are making the
problem of crime
worse every day with every minute that
anyone spends in our prisons
what about if you're a policymaker
i don't know who the job of this lies
with
whether it's the prime minister or some
government body or something but what if
you're
that particular policymaker and you say
right
we're going to shut down all of the
prisons
and then someone gets out and they cause
uh right they they go on a a murdering
spree or there's
someone who kills someone that that is
the sort of press
nightmare that is sufficient to probably
stop this from happening
no well that's what's happening now time
and again people are coming out of
prison and going on to commit violent
crime including murder
within a short time of their release so
i talk in the book i tell the story of
the tragic case of
the two young people who were killed on
london bridge uh
last year and usman khan who was their
killer had been in prison for eight
years
eight full years 24 hours a day in a
high security prison
and within a year he went out and killed
two young people stabbed them to death
on on london bridge
so that's what's happening now chris at
the moment the system is that we chuck
people back onto the streets and they go
out and commit terrible crimes
and my argument is if we've done
something different with him for those
eight years and it's a big opportunity
if you've got eight years with
someone to work with them i mean if you
had eight years of tennis camp just
imagine how good your backhand would be
right so i mean i'm making light of it
but the fact is that it's just common
sense that if you spend eight years
keeping someone in terrible conditions
and they mix with other terrorists and
other criminals
and you do nothing to try and change
them their thought processes or give
them any other alternative
a way to spend their life then they're
going to come out and sadly in that case
it was a terrible lesson
and the interesting thing about that
case for me and i and again i talk about
this in the book
is that jack merritt who was one of the
two young men who were killed by usman
khan
his father david after jack's death
he came out publicly and said don't use
my son's death as an excuse for longer
prison sentences
because my son didn't believe that long
prison sentences don't
work and i don't believe that they don't
work and when you have the father of
someone who's just been stabbed to death
by a long-term prisoner saying
that don't blame the shorter sentences
you need to start looking at doing
something different when a father in his
grief is prepared to say that
then people need to start listening um
yeah you're right that's someone who's
very much prepared to put their
principles before their emotions right
i mean well and the evidence because
it's the evidence that matters to me the
evidence is that prison doesn't work
the evidence is that when you move to a
system like they have in norway
where you very rarely use prison but
when you do you make it as normal as
possible people live in normal housing
units they've got kitchens they cook
it's not a great big kind of you know
shawshank redemption scenario
then in norway only 20 of prisoners come
out and reoffend
and they're the most violent ones
because they don't send the others to
prison in the first place
in our system it's up to 75 percent so
the norway system where you
treat people humanely and you normalize
the conditions works
the american and to a large extent the
british model of kind of
oppressive uh prison regimes with high
walls and fences and all the rest of it
doesn't work it makes crime worse and it
makes people's lives worse
so just use the evidence use common
sense apart from anything
i think upon reading the book
the thing that struck me was that
i believe the public's idea
of what the purpose of
the current litigative uh makeup the
current sort of crime and punishment
uh justice system in the uk is decoupled
from what actually works
to a degree where it's going to be very
very difficult to bring that bifurcation
back in line
so i think that most people believe that
prison is supposed to be a punishment
that there is some form of
penance to be paid by someone they've
done this thing
stolen robbed defrauded
hurt assaulted whatever it might be um
therefore
they should have some liberties taken
away they should be put into some form
of discomfort
um that this is some kind of recompense
right for them to come back um and i
think that
there are some people out there who
would want that
even if it didn't result in less crime
because of a sense of at its truer sense
how they believe
justice to be performed does that make
sense
it totally makes sense and what you're
describing in a nutshell
is the old testament idea of an eye for
an eye and of course
if you take the eye of someone who's
taken your eye it doesn't actually
bring your eye back and actually you end
up with someone who's lost their eye and
is probably deeply resentful against the
system and
and will go out and take someone else's
um but but you're right that that is
fundamental to the approach to justice
and i talk about in ancient times you
know going back to the mayans and the
romans
you know the idea that you take a life
as as or you
impose serious harsh prison or harsh
conditions or torture or something like
that
as a penalty for committing a crime it
goes back a long long long way it goes
thousands and thousands of years
but but the example i give of why that
doesn't matter and why we need to change
our ways now
is because back in those times people
thought that slavery was okay
you know it wasn't that long ago that
there was there was slavery in the
united states
and you know the fact of the matter is
just because we've always done something
doesn't mean we have to always carry on
doing it any more than we
carried on having slavery why do we
carry on having prisons that don't work
and that are deeply inhumane and deeply
destructive to the fabric of our society
as was slavery and as were many of the
other things that we don't do anymore
so you know we've come a long way in
some respects and we've changed certain
things
but the reality is in britain we still
criminalize ten year old children
and when you just think about that for a
second it's absolutely
catastrophic for the for the young
people involved
and for the society that we're sending
them out into when we've done it what's
the alternative we're going to close the
prisons what are people going to do
well my take on it is very
straightforward that you
look to the examples of prison systems
that do work
you use them as sparingly as possible so
for the 71 percent
sorry the 69 of prisoners who are
non-violent
i would send very very few of them into
a custodial environment or a prison
environment at all
because most of them are capable of
working
and of of contributing to society of
paying taxes and looking after their
kids
and the way in which you if you have to
restrict their movement for a period of
time we have the technology to do that
now we have
you know retina scans we have uh voice
recognition we have fingerprint scans
you can imprison people in their own
homes if you have to
and you can allow them the liberty to go
out and work if
you know as part of the day and you can
allow them to
to have restrictions to go to one place
but not to others there's
all this technology is available and it
would cost a fraction
of keeping someone locked up in an
actual prison which as i say is on
average 50
000 pounds a year to keep someone in
prison you know for
a fraction of that you could have the
technology to monitor them wherever they
go
you know where they are you know what
they're doing and you can allow them to
normalize their lives again
with a degree of control as much as
necessary you know the probation officer
can check in via zoom every day what are
you up to what's happening
yeah but at the moment they trudge along
to the probation office once a month
there's no supervision
and unsurprisingly they're either back
on drugs or they're back selling drugs
or they're back committing crime
but use the technology instead of the
walls
that's the point i'm making for the vast
majority of non-violent
and not inherently dangerous prisoners
and for the rest
and the ones that have to be in prison
because they represent a risk to the
public because they might commit a rape
or a murder or a serious
violent robbery keep the prison
conditions as normal as possible
have them living not in cells in cell
blocks with jangling keys and all the
rest of it
have them living in normal residential
blocks of accommodation with with
kitchens to prepare their own food
with rooms and you know yes you've got
to secure the perimeter
for the most dangerous people but you
actually don't need a 40 foot high
concrete or brick wall to secure a
perimeter these days
again when you have all of the
technology we have you know to thermal
imaging and everything else to make sure
that people can't escape
all you need is a fairly unobtrusive
fence of
sufficient height to stop people getting
out what you don't need and and
therefore people will move around
relatively freely inside
yeah only the absolute tiny number of
immediately violent people who are
likely to
harm anyone that comes in their site
will need to be secured in what what
might look like a cell but you keep it
as normal as possible and the reason for
that is
going back to the point i made earlier
on if you treat people normally
they are much more likely to behave
normally when they come out of that
environment
so you know it's it's not something that
you do overnight i'm not suggesting that
you start you know
next week with the bulldozer and knock
every prison and let everybody out
it would take it would be a rolling
program of replacing one group of
prisons with another
and replacing in policy terms instead of
locking people up
using all of the technology which is all
available to keep them secure in their
homes or in another environment might be
it might be a hostel it might be
somewhere else depending on their
circumstances
but don't put them behind these
monstrosities of
of concrete walls and great big brick
walls where their soul and their spirit
will be sapped and destroyed
and they'll come out violent and angry
because that's what happens now
is making the consequences of committing
a crime
by prison now being at home
with your family potentially still being
able to go to work with more liberty and
access to fresh air and so on and so
forth whenever you want
does that not act as less of a deterrent
is that not going to cause people to
have less fear about committing crime in
the first place
well the evidence all suggests that it
doesn't because in every
uh form of sentencing the least punitive
sentencing
and the most normal the lifestyle of the
person who's been sentenced
the less likely they are to commit
another crime so the one
form of punishment the one form of
sentence that has the
largest rate of recidivism or
reoffending
is prison everything else has a lower
rate of recidivism and it's not
surprising is it
because as i say if you are normalized
and allowed to live in society
with whatever restrictions are needed um
you you have continuity of your life
you can maintain very important things
all of us take for granted
you mentioned your mum being usher all
of us take for granted that we have
these sort of family networks most of us
do anyway we have our parents or we have
you know our our other half or or kids
or
or a wider network of family and friends
people in prison have
none of that most of that disappears
well particularly when people are
serving very long sentences
so the point about keeping people in the
community is those are the things that
keep most of us grounded
and most of us on you know even if we
have tough times and we might be feeling
getting angry about stuff
we've got people around us and we've got
support mechanisms and
and that's why keeping people out of
prison unless it's
absolutely essential is so much more
successful
at keeping people in the long run from
committing more crimes and it's an
absolute cast iron statistical fact
wherever you look in the world that the
worst outcomes are the most punitive
prisons
they create the most recidivism the most
reoffending
so again anybody if people want to have
an eye for an eye
and the public do vote for it you know
when a politician says
oh we're going to increase sentences for
criminals the public clap
and they vote for it so obviously people
make that choice with their eyes open
realizing as you a point you made
earlier chris well maybe people won't
care maybe people won't care if we
double the risk that someone commit
another murder provided we punish them
harshly well if people are prepared to
accept the risk that their son or their
daughter will be murdered
because we are giving somebody a harsh
sentence in prison
then people need to accept that but that
needs to be put on the table as part of
the debate
and politicians need to acknowledge that
the the sentences and the
and the you know long long sentences for
things like drug crime they need to say
okay we're going to do this because you
want us to not because it works
and then we'll see what we'll see what
the debate looks like when people are
honest at the moment there's no honesty
you hear you hear the home secretary
pretty patel you hear the prime minister
before the election
get tough on criminals crack down make
them you know quiver in their boots
criminals don't quiver in their boots at
the thought of being locked up in prison
because they don't think they're going
to get caught
that's the most important part of
criminal justice and deterrence
none of my clients over 26 years went
out one day and thought said i know i'm
going to get caught for this and i'm
going to get 10 years but i'm going to
do it anyway
they don't think they're going to get
caught that's why prison isn't a
deterrent
that's why it isn't a deterrent in
america where you can get life without
parole for selling an ounce of weed
in some states you know p people don't
get up in the morning and think oh and i
could get life without parole for this
i'm going to go and sell the weed anyway
i think i'm going to get away with it
and most of the time they do
and that's why deterrence in prison
doesn't work because people don't think
about getting caught
what you need to look at is why are
people out there doing these things in
the first place
and they're out there in most cases
because they have broken lives and
broken lives based on a broken childhood
and that's why i'm so keen on reforming
the way we deal with children in
particular when they get caught up in
the criminal system
let's talk about it why why are children
never criminals
because i i one of the things that i
just don't understand
is the mentality that says that you have
to be 18
to be wise enough and mature enough to
vote you have to be 18 to make a choice
to drink alcohol or to smoke cigarettes
and there are all sorts of other age
restrictions you know for different
activities you have to be 21 a thing to
drive a lorry for example
but somehow or other at the age of 10
you know just think about 10 year old
child i mean i know if you if you if you
know if you have kids in your family i
mean i've got four kids my
own uh including an 11 year old and
and a nine-year-old actually and the
idea that either of them
would have their kind of maturity to
understand
what crime is yes they know right from
wrong on a basic simple level
but the idea that you treat them the
same having the same understanding of
crime
as an 18 year old or 70 70 year old
is just ridiculous it's just absolutely
and
i know i explained in the book how there
are countries and and
you know even saudi arabia has an older
age of criminal responsibility than us
you know and they're hardly a beacon of
civilization when it comes to criminal
justice
but but luxembourg is the beacon for me
because in luxembourg what i've
advocated in the book is the law in
other words you can't be convicted of
any crime
unless you are 18 or over it's the same
age to vote and it's the same age that
you're capable of deem capable of
committing a crime
and in their system if a child commits
what would be a crime
for an adult they don't call him a
criminal they don't call him a prisoner
they just call him a child
and they say okay a 10 year old or 11
year old or even a 15 year old has done
a bad thing
what they do is they work with them in
an educational environment
they don't put them in a prison
environment and our young offenders
institutions are
prisons in all but name and they are
hell holes for those young people inside
them
uh who are called young offenders
they're labeled young offenders
point i was making earlier you label
someone with something they will be that
thing
they will act to that that description
and that label and young offenders
become
adult criminals and often they go in and
out in a revolving door
for 20 or 30 years and they cost us
millions
both in terms of the cost of locking
them up and the crimes they commit
and we just keep on doing it so if you
divert children
from 10 11 12 years old when most of the
sort of
the more hardcore kind of element that
end up in prison start
their life of crime or their life of
involvement with the police
if you divert them at 10 11 12 away from
the criminal justice system and into the
education system and the welfare system
then you have a chance of saving them
from that revolving door for the rest of
their life
and saving the rest of us a load of
money and a load of grief
does that mean no such thing as a
criminal record for people under the age
of 18.
absolutely not there should not be a
criminal record for someone under the
age of 18.
and again it goes back to the same point
we were discussing earlier about about
yes there's a hardcore
of people in our society who are
inherently dangerous
they might assault people rape people or
or hurt people in one way or another
amongst children that group is tiny a
tiny number of 10 11 12 year olds
are already so dangerous that they have
to be physically secured from others
it's a tiny tiny number but even those
they're not going to spend their life
locked away so you still have to be
humanely working on what it is that is
going to
uh make them change the way they're
living their lives and and as i said
many of them that get
caught up in the system pro you know the
majority in fact in the early
part of the criminal justice the youth
justice system many of them
um are just a product of of a horrific
childhood and an
experience of being in the care system
and we're responsible for that chris
you you me the rest of us the adults
that vote for
the way in which society organizes
itself and and decides what care what
the care system is and what it looks
like and decide how much money to spend
on it
and decide how much we care about it
we're responsible for those kids
and we need to take responsibility not
just throw them in youth prisons and
then in adult prisons in later life
got you what about drugs why are you you
proposing that we legalize drugs all
drugs every drug should they be
available on a street corner
no not on the street corner but yes to
all drugs um
so my model for the licensing and
regulation of drugs so i don't use the
word legalization because what you don't
do
is allow drug dealers to just sell drugs
freely because that's that's one of the
worst elements of the drug market we
have now
is that the market is in the hands of
violent criminals and i've represented
many of them
and and they care about only one thing
and that is profit and getting as many
people as possible to take drugs
so you take the market away from them
and you have licensed
regulated supply networks which are
highly regulated by the state just as
pubs are
you know if you're if you're a serious
criminal you can't get a license to run
a pub
you can't get a license to sell alcohol
um
alcohol is a highly regulated product
that you know that you have to have
warning labels you have to have a
percentage of alcohol on the label
people have to know exactly what they're
getting when they buy alcohol and my
model for regulation is
exactly the same as alcohol so you have
age restrictions on certain products
which might be different for different
products
but at the end of the day the idea is
and i tell the story that probably the
most tragic
section of the whole book is the story
of martha fernbach who was a young girl
of 15
who went out one saturday and with her
friends who were all sort of teenagers
around the same age they decided to take
some mdma
some ecstasy in effect um some mda mdma
powder
and they've done it a couple of times
before and it was okay but on this
occasion
martha ended up with a bag of mdma
powder that was 91
pure and she took enough she had no idea
what she was taking because there's no
label on it
she took enough to kill a horse and she
died within a couple of hours
of taking or a couple of days i should
say of taking the
the mdma powder and the interesting
thing about that i mean it's a horrific
thought that a 15 year old has got this
see-through packet you know if she asked
someone to go to the off license for her
to buy a bottle of wine or
you know or whatever whatever she might
want it in terms of alcohol
she might get very drunk but she she
know what she was doing she'd know what
was going into her body
um and she might make bad choices like
many of us did as teenagers
but but when it comes to drugs you just
get a see-through packet from a dealer
in a back alley
and you don't know whether it's 91 or 1
or 00
and it's the equivalent of sending a
child into a pub and saying drink this
drink
and we're not telling you what's in it
and it might kill you but we don't know
until you've drunk it
and that's the way that we're allowing
drugs to enter into people's bodies in
our society
and and it's all based on an absolutely
ridiculous belief
that we can stop people taking drugs by
making it a crime
you know people have been taking drugs
as i say in the book for hundreds of
millions of years since the beginning of
evolution
of the modern human there is evidence of
people taking psychotropic psychoactive
plants
people have been taking drugs of one
kind or another for the entire
history of human evolution so the whole
idea that you're going to stop people
doing something so fundamental
as taking drugs is ridiculous and if you
can't stop people doing it you need to
make it safe as possible
and you need to also not only make it
safe for the users who are overdosing in
massive numbers
because of the very features i've just
pointed out but you also need to wipe
out the crimes that these people commit
because to keep up a habit of street
drugs of heroin or crack
or even a heavy cocaine habit it costs
hundreds of pounds a day
and the only way that drug users can get
hold of hundreds of pounds a day is to
commit crime
or to sell themselves on the street and
many sadly many drug users are in the
sex
industry uh often in a very very poor
state of mental and physical health and
selling themselves
to strangers just to fund a habit where
they should be getting those drugs in a
much more humane licensed system
and i saw in action in switzerland as
you know from the book you know i saw
the heroin assisted treatment program
where
you know they treat heroin users as if
they have a medical condition that needs
to be helped
they don't treat them as criminals that
need to be kind of marginalized from
society and locked up
and one of the one of the wonderful
things chris i'm sorry to to go on about
this because it's one of my major
passions but
but one of the things that the head of
that heroin assisted
treatment program told me was the the
users of that service
mostly long-term chronic heroin addicts
they already think that they're [ __ ]
when they go in there they don't need
the police or the courts or someone else
telling them that [ __ ] they feel like
[ __ ] already
and that's one of the many reasons why
sadly they become addicted to heroin
it's only when you show your compassion
and kindness
and give them proper medical care and
give them safe heroin
safe needles you test them for hiv you
test them for hepatitis you give them
health care
that's when they start to feel less [ __ ]
about themselves and that's when they
start to take fewer drugs and the
success of that program in getting
people off drugs
by actually giving them heroin is quite
unbelievable
compared to any comparable criminal
justice outcome
where the success of getting people off
drugs is negative in fact more people
take drugs
when they've gone through the system
than before they went in
it's crazy we're killing people we're
killing people in this country
it's so circular the crime is needed to
pay for the drugs which are overpriced
because
the dealers are there's too much um
costing implications in terms of
transportation and the ability for the
quality to be
uh [ __ ] around with which means so i i
first heard about the
um switzerland heroin program from
johann hari's
chasing the stream yeah i did a call
with him recently
uh an online event with him he's a great
guy yes yeah past modern wisdom guest
and a wonderful
wonderful fellow i imagine that you two
had a really good conversation
we did yeah we did it he i mean i mean
anybody that is prepared to
to speak truth to power as he as he has
done
over in recent years is someone that
needs to be listened to no
absolutely he's a a real sort of voice
for it so again with this there's just
each of the chapters closing prisons
children being criminals legalizing
drugs good and evil
internet of crime like all of the stuff
in your book
is uh increasingly difficult
red pill to swallow about
what the common held narrative
perhaps either by press or by
our own um
perception our own uninformed perception
of what
is effective policy making and what is
effective justice
um those two things continue to just be
further and further apart had it not
been for me reading chasing the screen
by
johann i would have looked at why should
we legalize drugs as a [ __ ] mental
title
but yeah having read that and then i'm
like increasingly
more and more and more people that i
respect and who have done the work
and have the stats to back it up agree
with you
yeah and we're all we're actually trying
it a little bit i think we're dipping
our toe in the water i say we but the
scottish are dipping their toe in the
water with a heroin assisted treatment
program
on a small scale but the truth of it is
that that
i would love the home secretary or the
prime minister to go and visit that
clinic and
that i went to in geneva and indeed some
of the other facilities that i visited
in in switzerland like the
consumption rooms where people can take
their own drugs
which is not ideal for my point of view
but at least they can take their drugs
in hygienic conditions they get given
clean needles they get given the
opportunity to
to wash to access health care uh i i
prefer that they work they were all in
in a treatment program but but at least
they are kept safe
and much safer than they would be in
britain um but i would love
our politicians to go and visit some of
those programs instead of just standing
on their soap box saying
drugs are terrible drug crimes terrible
and we need to just crack down on it all
the time because
every time you crack down we've had all
these raids recently uh
even during lockdown drug crime is going
up and up because drug drug dealers are
relentless they're never going to stop
because there's so much money in it
in just industrious jobs they are they
are very ingenious and i've had drugs
drug trafficking clients who are major
dealers you know who bring in tons of
weed a month or
tens of millions of cocaine a month into
the country
and they are some of the most bright
sophisticated uh
and business-minded people i've ever met
because it is a business and as you say
it's a logistics business it's about how
do you get
poppies in afghanistan turned into
heroin and then transported in packets
or in
in in in vehicles or by any other means
how do you get that to someone's vein
in london or manchester or or carlisle
and and every time you move it from a to
b there's a
there's a layer of profit and there's
someone who has to be bribed and this
you can produce pharmaceutical heroin
for almost nothing
it's a very cheap product to produce and
and that's why
people say oh but you're giving them
thousands of pounds worth of heroin a
week
for free you're not you're giving them
you know maybe less than 100 pounds a
week because it doesn't cost that much
to produce most drugs
what costs money is to illegally
transport them
from where they originate to someone who
wants to use it in a in
a in a western society that's why you go
into the markets in
pakistan or afghanistan you could buy a
kilo of heroin for about a thousand
dollars
by the time that reaches the streets of
britain it's a hundred thousand
and that's why it's so much that's why
pure kilo of heroin
uh it goes up from a thousand dollars to
a hundred thousand by the time it's been
transported and cut onto the streets
so the government could license heroin
production as they have done of course
and heroin is produced for
pharmaceutical reasons
and they could produce it for next to
nothing and we would cut out all of that
criminal profit and we would get rid of
those criminals once and for all
who would do it are you going to have
off licenses on
sort of treatment facilities like
pharmacies where people can go and get
mdma i think that it would make sense to
have the premises initially operated
directly by the state
and there are different types of
premises so rather than private business
making a profit from
it um i think it because the government
has to be able to supply
sorry government has to be able to
supply um
control the price because if the
government can't control the price
then you may create the room for their
for the criminals to remain in the
market
so the government has to very precisely
control the price and of course
with alcohol prices vary there's no
there's no restriction on pricing in
alcohol
it can go up it can go down but i think
you need to be very careful
so and you'd need different kinds of
facilities so with heroin which is a
drug
almost entirely of addiction it's not a
not a drug that people take
are most mostly on a night out or a
weekend
or a weekend clubbing or whatever with
heroin you would have
medical facilities to dispense heroin in
the swiss model
with other drugs that you i don't call
them recreational drugs because because
drugs are just drugs
you know and people use them for even
so-called recreational drugs like
ecstasy cocaine and cannabis
are often used by people who have got
you know serious issues they may have
addictions they may have
other kind of um psychiatric or
emotional problems that cause them to
try and
mask pain just as people do with alcohol
so i i you know yes and there are others
there are you know
fairly fair number of drug users who
just use drugs for recreation they go
out the weekend
and it really has a relatively little
ill effect they carry on with their life
and their work
and i think those drugs that we might
call recreational drugs
you would access them through a licensed
dispensary and and initially i think it
would have to be a government-run one
because i just don't like the idea of
private business getting into the profit
model for drugs i don't think it works
but for drugs
um and i'm not sure we would have a
profit model alcohol industry if we'd
started you know if we started again
um but i would i would have license
dispensaries and you'd go in you'd have
to tick a couple of boxes sign a couple
of forms and and you'd make it
relatively straightforward to get the
drugs um but you would nevertheless
everybody that got drugs they would have
access to
you know helplines or even face-to-face
counselling if they felt that they had a
problem
and it and that you don't get that from
drug dealers drug dealers don't say okay
we'll give you your drugs tick this box
here's a number and a card if you think
you've got a problem
you know ring this number and we'll get
you to see someone tomorrow who can give
you something
drug dealers really should try and
improve their service if they can
the after the aftercare is you know
apple
applecare i'm gonna do you want the
extended warranty on this on this bag of
mdma
yeah a lot of different ways that we
could go about it
so here's just as you're speaking and
having really enjoyed
the book here's what here's my
suggestion or here's my thoughts on
what i think drives this point home and
what i think is missing
and it's it's an emotive
way to grab people's attention and
the reason that i say that is i have a
buddy alex o'connor who's a
vegan philosopher um so he justifies
veganism from an armchair philosophy
perspective
and he has wholly convinced me of the
moral position
of veganism and and yet
i don't have as much of a visceral
response as when i see chicks getting
thrown into a grinder
now i don't i don't disagree that
you need the philosophical
where do you where do you go out chris
where you see chicks getting thrown into
grinders where
where is this place i'm worried about
your social life well i'm from newcastle
chris so you get some weird stuff up
here mate
you get some really bizarre stock
fighting the whole thing
full works full full works yeah exactly
so james's park's a hell of a night out
um
i'll bring it i'll bring a bag of chips
a bag of chicks and we'll get out next
time we'll throw throw something into a
grinder yeah that's it
um yeah smoke some weed i um
i he's convinced me of the moral
framework that underpins it
what it does not drive that point home
this is something as much as i'm not a
huge fan of his podcast but it's
something that i think russell brand has
done
uh fantastically with some of his stuff
on tv is
how he's re-purposed um
sort of moved the window of how people
view drug dealers
i think a lot of the general public
especially like the kind of
classic british middle class just see it
as
people having a low-key party 24 7.
their heroin dealers have you know
they're in a smoky hazy room somewhere
it's like a you know like a real budget
version of probably what dan bilzerian
sees
the reality appears to be much
much more um disgusting
well yeah drug dealers are mostly the
great majority of so-called drug dealers
are actually just low-level users who
are just selling on behalf of someone
else or they're
they're cutting their own drugs just to
try and get enough for themselves
many of them have got serious health
problems i mean i tell this tragic story
in the book of
of of a guy who got you know he was a
heroin user and he got caught up in
uh in low-level dealing and he got
beaten to death
for a uh for allegedly stealing a
caravan yeah
yeah allegedly seeing a few hundred quid
from his boss basically he was also a
low-level dealer himself
and that's what happens in a criminal
market and so yes i talked about the
sort of
what you might call the sort of big time
drug dealers uh
who are who represent like anything you
know there's only one
chief exec of you know tescos most
people are shelf stackers and work on
the tills and the drug markets the same
there's only one guy who's really making
it big
everybody else along the way has a
miserable life where they're much more
likely to die
young they're much more likely to get
serious health problems so the whole
industry
is built on misery as it stands at the
moment do we have a
equivalent of rico in the uk
well not so much uh we we don't
specifically have legislation that
targets
targets gang activities as a whole
but we have plenty of laws that cover uh
you know organized crime activity but
they are they're usually related to
specific conduct like
supplying class a drugs or or serious
fraud or people trafficking
so we don't we don't go down the
american kind of federal model of trying
to criminalize whole gangs just for
being gangs
um we we focus on them committing
specific crimes
but it amounts to much the same because
most organized crime activity
is around the drug market uh by by
volume by by the number of people
involved and by the value
of the of of the transactions so
we you know and we spend a vast amount
we spend billions on criminalizing the
drug
on investigating and prosecuting drug
dealers and we spend
a tiny fraction of that on health
services for serious long-term drug
users and that's an absolute scandal
because if we did try to help users
with real medical programs that have
been proven all over the world to work
we'd have not only will have a kinder
society but we'd have a much safer one
uh not just for them but for all of us
and that's the real tragedy that we're
doing all of these things
we're criminalizing mostly fairly
hopeless people
for selling a few you know an ounce here
or or a few grams there
and and and sometimes get sending them
away for five six seven years for
selling
like i say an ounce of coke or something
like that why
what's the point of that what does that
achieve i'll tell you what it achieves
it takes one dealer off the street
takes one ounce of coke or even if it's
100 kilos all that happens is if you get
a drug drought
because there's been loads of
enforcement activity the price goes up
so the profits go up and you know it's a
blind demand adam smith turning over in
his grave here yeah
absolutely absolutely and we we're we
just don't get it and
and that's why lock down drug crimes up
because there was a big interaction
yeah absolutely i'll tell you why and
there was a big there was a load of drug
violence and
gang violence going on during lockdown
and i know that from speaking to those
who are kind of directly involved in
policing those activities
um and the reason was because there was
an interruption in the supply chain
because it was very difficult to move
anything during lockdown
in the first weeks of lockdown so what
happens is that people are then selling
stock
or what little they can get through at
much higher prices
and that means there's even more of a
premium on territory if you if you're
if you can sell your kilo for 300 grand
on the street instead of 100
you need to make sure no one else is
selling on your streets because you want
the 300 grand
so that's why the stabbings and the
murders carried on during lockdown
they carried on because people could get
even
more profit than they could ever get
before um and and
if that doesn't tell you that you're
doing something wrong that you're
locking you're locking down the whole of
society
but the drug market still operates if
that doesn't tell you that the war on
drugs
is always going to fail then nothing
will it's a [ __ ] it's a robust market
chris if we could totally and since time
began if we could
harness the innovative
power and the uh logistical and
operational talents
i've got i got a number of different
tasks that need doing inside of my
company
that that would be fantastic for someone
with the lateral thinking
that is really common in the drug market
apparently
what did you what did you learn about
the dark web in the internet of crime
you had a look at that
yeah i did and and it's fascinating
topic as you know it kind of it's
it may well lead into another book i
suspect um because i i was absolutely
fascinated by i i
in the book in that particular in the
epilogue of the book about
my involvement in one of the original
kind of internet based kind of internet
piracy cases many years ago which looks
very quaint compared to the
to the dark web now you know it's a cute
cottage industry that
yeah well back then it was just getting
a load of dvd recorders and and and
you know um creating copies of dvds or
cds or whatever of course that whole
world has changed and
and you know and it's a very different
world now but no i talk in the book
about my own kind of journey if you like
into the dark web
and and and how surprising it was to me
that it was so easy to access
because i had i had some help with it
but it took
less than 10 minutes to go from google
and just just looking at normal like
websites like the bbc etc
and then suddenly within 10 minutes of
setting up a vpn all the rest of it
i'm being offered any drug i could
possibly imagine in any quantity in any
purity i'm being offered guns i'm being
offered
hit men i'm on the rabbit hole there
down the rabbit hole
i took a left i took a left turn at
google oh bloody hell don't do that
again i know
listen i mean you'd have to deliberately
do it you have to download the right
software you have to have the right
browsers and everything else and
you wouldn't get there by accident
that's the whole point it doesn't it's
not
accessible via ordinary browsers or or
via ordinary uh
internet connections you have to do it
via vpn et cetera you can't get there
but once you get there
all of this darkness is there all of
this unregulated criminal market and you
know the fact that you can buy
firearms where they promise they will
send the components they will break it
down into how many pieces they'll send
your firearm with bullets
they'll break it down into 10 or 20
pieces and get it through customs
without detection and if you lose one of
the pieces they'll send you a
replacement
and you then reassemble the firearm you
get bullets included in the deal
and bob's your uncle you're on the
street with a with a with an ak-47
within sort of 48 hours of placing your
order and it's a scary scary world
and and it made me sort of think that
much of my
kind of 25 years plus in criminal law
looks like not it doesn't look like it's
the last quarter century
it looks like it was a century ago you
know but when i started out people still
very regularly went out with shotguns
and battle clubs and committed armed
robberies that hardly happens now
because of dna evidence and
and tracking of vehicles and ampr which
is you know number plate recognition
systems
you know it's very few and of course
they inc they have special dyes on all
the banknotes so
you can hardly ever get away with armed
robbery but but on the internet
on the dark web you can get away with
almost anything
and it's really absolutely scary but
it's also fascinating i found it
fascinating because you know
it was a world that i didn't really know
and it very rarely me gets into the sort
of hands of the criminal courts because
people can operate from anywhere i mean
while i was on there
you know my vpn was was moving location
to obviously to avoid any form of
detection
and one minute it looked like i was in
south korea then i was somewhere else
and
it's impossible to track venezuela you
know
and and and and you know there's going
to be a real challenge in our society so
so definitely looking ahead to
potentially another book and and
my book's only published today so maybe
this is looking ahead too quickly but
but i'm going to go to russia and some
of these other places where they have
these sort of deep web
dark web rather kind of hackers and so
on who are
who are masterminding hundreds of
millions and billions in fact of dollars
a year
in trade in drugs and crime and people
you know there's lots of child
prostitution
um and and and it'll be fascinating to
see what's happening but also
in the next book i may look at how law
enforcement is responding to it and
whether in fact
as i say in the book it's a battle that
can never be won
or if it's not [ __ ] kansas anymore
this is it
no you're absolutely right absolutely
not and i i think you're correct as well
that as with everything at the moment
if you look at the amount of wealth that
someone like jeff bezos or bill gates
has been able to accrue
leveraged by technology it's orders of
magnitude more
than the the next closest like
well textile man cotton manufacturer
from like the 1800s or something like
you know what
what what are we comparing this to
because the amount of leverage you can
get on technology is so disproportionate
and then if you roll that forward it's
not like criminals
as we've identified they're [ __ ]
smart
like really really scary scary smart
um and some of them not all of them
chris
i'm sure you've encountered your own the
ones that don't get caught are the
smartest and so they never crossed my
they never come across my desk but uh
yeah but even the ones who do you're
absolutely right
i made the point i mean i had a i had a
drug dealing client he was importing
uh i think a couple of tons of weed a
week he was one of the largest uh sort
of importers of weed
and he did get himself caught and he
only got caught actually because the
police had put surveillance devices in
his house
uh and were recording all of his
conversations even in his house which is
really quite unusual and and was unusual
then to get a warrant for
for a domestic sort of property like
that um but i remember sitting down with
him i went to see him in prison many
many times and eventually he you know
we did a deal and he got a relatively
light sentence but but i remember saying
to him
you know uh at the time you know you're
such a clever guy
you've got you're all over this he knew
every page of the evidence he was
incredibly articulate
fiercely intelligent but he dropped out
of school at 14 and ended up
just going going and sort of kind of
bombing around and committing crime and
and then just the only world he knew was
crime and so he applied that fierce
intelligence and that
and he had enormous business sense you
know that kind of you know how the best
entrepreneurs can spot an opportunity
can and can motivate the troops
but he had no education and he had no no
formal education of any kind
and he just decided to apply his mind to
a business that was illegal and he made
millions from it until he got caught
unfortunately for him because he was
cannabis rather than cocaine or heroin
he ended up doing i think about four
years whereas if it had been cocaine or
heroin and this no doubt was part of his
calculation actually
uh but if it been cocaine or heroin
you've got 25 or 30 years for the same
thing
so um you know and even that was a he
was taking a calculated risk
yeah as as to which drug to deal you
know
the uh i think the um the dark web stuff
i went really really far down the rabbit
hole of the ross ulbricht
uh uh yeah case um he was the the
guy behind the original silk road and
i've done
my fair bit of uh of rabbit hole
tumbling about that
so i would um i would absolutely love to
find out some more stuff if you go to
russia and and
find out yesterday from these deep web
hackers that's something you have to
come as well chris
may i'm i am in if you if you want to
road trip me
out to russia i i have no
there is never been a flight i haven't
got on that someone suggested haven't
bottled a dare since 2001 and i don't
intend on doing it now crystal qc
um what's the most common criticisms
about your proposals can you steal man
the other side of this argument yeah
definitely so so the argument i get most
is what about the victims
you know victims want justice victims
want punishment
and and they don't care about all of
your ideas and what does or doesn't work
if they've been raped or if they've been
robbed or if they've had their you know
their house burgled they want to see
some vengeance they want to see some
justice
so so that's one of the arguments that's
put to me as far as drugs are concerned
the false argument is
always put which is we're going to have
more drug use
and actually in any deregulated or in
particular heavily regulated or licensed
market what you see is falling levels of
drug use they saw it when they
decriminalized the possession of drugs
in portugal
many years ago and they have had
massively positive outcomes from that
and
not they don't go far enough for me
because they because they still allow
criminals to deal drugs
um but they they decriminalized users
and they made use as part of the
healthcare system
drug use fell crime fell and health
outcomes improved
so so those arguments are made um and
in so far as children are concerned i
always get this
what about the jamie bulger case they
know
they know right from wrong at that age
and therefore they should be able to
take the consequences so
so people have this kind of view and and
you know it's not an unusual one and i i
i'm quite happy to accept chris
i'm probably in a minority of about 30
of the population that's prepared to
kind of listen to evidence and to think
about these things without getting
carried away with the gut and the
emotion of being
passionate about it's hard man like even
me as someone
i've never the closest i've ever come
to a court is when i've picked my mum up
from work if a car's been
an mot like i i don't have any of my
family who've ever been
in you know i am i am the the absolute
epitome uh avatar for that person
that middle class british person who
hasn't got a [ __ ] clue what's going
on
and for me i'm i'm as you're talking as
i was reading the book and
these proposals come up and everyone
that's listening may have noticed this
as well
i have to check my immediate visceral
emotional reaction
because there is something that's been
programmed into me to fear the other
right it's quite tribal yeah the way
that i
oh no no keep them away don't want them
on the street don't want them door on
them
like who's them who am i talking about
to myself when i say
them on the street you mean those other
humans born in the same country as you
with the same rights as you
that did a thing like is that is that
genuinely the way
so you know all of this um the the
proposals that you're putting forward
i think upon
reflection like with real nuanced
thought they do
make sense and land but there's a
challenge as we know
like look at you know trump run 2016 on
build that wall and
make america great again the simple
visceral response
often is actually the one which is able
to elicit
the the best output the best outcome
from
the audience oh totally so that's you
know that's the point i make is that
uh i talk in the book about some appeal
judges that i interviewed uh and
criminal judges i interviewed in alabama
um none of them would go on the record
which was perhaps understandable um
but they're all elected judges so they
they're they're judges unlike ours
who are appointed um their judges are
elected directly by the public
and i said to one of the courts of
appeal judges you know you've you've
given people the death penalty
you've sent people of 18 years old
for life without parole for a drug crime
uh you you regularly sentence people to
100 years in prison
for crimes that are not even violent
crimes they might be you know fraudulent
or white collar crimes
i said you know looking at your system
you have these millions of people
2.3 million people in prison in the
states and you know
as you know from the book i caught i
call it the city of incarceration be the
fifth largest city in america if
if you put them all in one place it's
just that you just think about the
numbers they're actually mindful
but i said to this judge i said you know
so so you're doing all of these things
but your your level of violence and
murder in particular is the highest in
the world and your rate of imprisonment
is the highest in the world
so and he said to me he turned around he
said i know i know it's crackers
he said it's crazy it's completely crazy
and i said but why'd you do it then i
don't understand you've got you're stuck
sitting on that bench
and he said two things he said the
sentences are dictated by guidelines and
i'm not allowed to
to to move from them the guidelines are
set by effectively the legislators the
politicians are elected
and he said secondly if i came out on
television and said i'm in favor
of legalizing drugs reducing the prison
population and starting to have a much
more benevolent youth justice system
he said i'd be out of office in five
minutes no one would vote for me
so so his point was it's all very well
you saying
and he acknowledges that it's all wrong
but if he wants a job
he's got to carry on playing the same
old tune just as i'm sure many uh
uh southern politicians in the states
after slavery was abolished
you know they didn't want that they
didn't like it and and it was kicking
the screen it was fought by a civil war
to get to get slavery abolished
you know and that was only
to get some justice reform uh do you
know i i wonder
if we keep creeping towards american
levels of imprisonment and we are we've
doubled our own prison population in a
generation
in britain if we keep creeping that way
i wonder whether the british people will
actually then look at the increasing
rates of murder on the streets
because that's what will happen and
start to say
hold on a minute it wasn't like this 20
years ago and they'd be right
we doubled our prison population but
we've got double the number of murders
because i'll guarantee that's what
happened
and just then maybe people will start to
say to their politicians when it comes
to an election
what are you actually going to do about
it that works yes we're sick of our kids
being stabbed and
shot it's the that works that
is the important uh distinction to make
because
the natural uneducated
uninformed view is get tougher on crime
yeah but what people mean is we want
less crime
well that's what people want so that's
what they mean
what they mean is we want to punish and
harm criminals we want to lock them up
in the worst conditions
make it tougher on them that's what they
want so that's the presumption of that
is that that is going to act as an
effective deterrent so that there is
less crime however as you've said there
are some people who
want this retributive approach
to the way that that justice is enacted
especially those
who perhaps are the victims or the
families of victims of crime
um but from a society wide perspective
you're right it's
it's what can we do that reduces
overall crime which in turn reduces
overall suffering
like what what are the options i mean
where where do we start then because it
this seems a little bit self-defeating
in a way if the policymakers are the
people who can
begin this change rolling down the hill
but
by proposing these particular policies
they then get unelected by
an uninformed public is it
a bottom-up public information
campaign that's needed is it top-down i
think it is and i think i think
i think it's a combination of the two i
mean if we had an inspirational
political leader
who came in what do you mean
chris is the voice of it he's the voice
of a generation
i'll start my sentence again if we if we
if we had an inspirational political
leader who was prepared to get behind
the idea of serious criminal justice
reform
and was popular and populist in the way
that for example tony blair was
um back in the in the 90s
and and and unfortunately he didn't do
do enough in my
mind on this topic um but if we had
an inspirational political leader to
come from the left or the center left
uh and win a big majority in parliament
who's prepared to back this agenda
that's one way it can happen so that's
the top-down model but the bottom-up
model is how it happened in switzerland
so in switzerland what happened was why
did they reform their approach to drugs
was because there was heroin users
dropping dead in the streets
uh shooting up in parks uh assaulting
people as they went about their daily
business and the people of switzerland
said you've got to clean up our streets
and make our streets safer so they took
the drugs away from the streets and they
put them into consumption rooms and
treatment programs and they then saw the
streets became safer for the public
and when that happened uh people were
prepared because in switzerland they
have an amazing system they have
referendums for everything
everything it happens by referendum so
it's only when the swiss people
decided that their streets were too
dangerous that they they voted
literally by referendum to bring in
heroin assisted treatment
to bring in the consumption rooms to
stop criminalizing um
low-level drug dealers and in the end
they gave drug users in switzerland
the same disability rights as any other
disabled person
and and they treat they treat addiction
to drugs or
alcohol or gambling or anything else as
a disability
to be treated and to be given support
from us from the state
and that was the bottom up so it could
happen either way can happen with an
inspiration and they had inspirational
prime minister a president rather in
switzerland who who was prepared to back
this agenda
and she did get support in elections and
she did get um support in referenda
so so so it worked in both directions in
switzerland
um and i think that for my part to
answer your question i think it could
happen
either way i would rather it happen
because it would happen more quickly
if we got an inspirational leader who
would back rational reform
because then that person could introduce
it and make it happen quickly it takes
much longer for a groundswell of
public opinion to drive the political
classes
and we're not seeing that i'm afraid at
the moment we're also not going to see
for i there's no way that i can sit
unless something catastrophic happens
there's no way i can see a left-leaning
government
getting in for at least another that's
because you're a young man chris and you
think that you think that where we are
now is where we'll be forever
no i mean i'm i'm talking at least the
the immediate future we've got four
years
and then yep unless you would have to
have the biggest swing in history
to reverse what just happened only six
months ago
um and well yeah but you're forgetting
the corbyn factor in in in that i mean
you
you had a deeply unpopular with the
majority of the electorate
um very left-wing labour leader
who who was never going to win election
if if he stood 100 times
we now have it we now have a younger we
have a younger more palatable leader of
the labour party i say we but you know
um in the country we have a younger more
palatable labour leader in fact one of
my
uh profession of course uh qc and former
head of the prosecution
service in in in england um
i i i'm i'm not so sure how many people
positively voted for johnson and of
course there was also the the the brexit
factor
in the last election it was pre-covered
i i don't think you could read
into the fact that that johnson won a
majority in very particular
circumstances
against a very unpopular and very
left-wing
labour leader the fact that and
extrapolate that through to the next
election
okay i think all to play for in the next
one i mean you know
my my goal with regards to this
conversation is just to
to get the reform on the right track i
i'd love to hear anyone that's listening
if you think that you have an
alternative to what chris
is suggesting here i'd love to hear it
but being honest it seems like
a um statistically
sound and
humanely um
comfortable and compassionate approach
to moving forward there's few arguments
that i can come up with in my mind
that aren't just those quite infantile
visceral
like yeah but what about this you know
it's just like a like a throwing around
point
it doesn't i don't have anything so with
that in mind when you can't rebut
an argument that's usually that that
presumably is when you win a case
yeah absolutely and and i you know
one of the most moving conversations
i've had in the last couple of years
was with uh the family so i made a
documentary series for the bbc
uh last year which went out on bbc one
it's still on eye player actually if
anyone wants to catch it it's called
crime
it was called crime are we tough enough
um and it's on bbc iplayer
um and it was five episodes and we
looked at different aspects of criminal
justice policy and and we traveled all
over the country i went into prisons and
we
interviewed prisoners and and i
interviewed the family of a young man
who had been stabbed to death outside a
pub in his twenties
uh his mother and father and his his
brother
um we sat around their dining table with
a picture of their son michael who who
died
uh in the background and they were
telling me
that they want that so the killer of
their son had
not long got out of prison for another
assault and he was released on license
and he had been arrested a couple of
other times
and wasn't recalled to prison and
therefore was at liberty one evening to
stab their son to death
and they were saying he should have been
in prison for longer
he should have got more prison time and
then he wouldn't have killed our son
and and it was a very difficult
conversation as you can imagine chris
because i come from it as you know from
a very different perspective
but i said to them can i just ask you to
look at it in a slightly different
way which is the the killer of your son
who was caught and sentenced to life
imprisonment by the way
um but i said to them the killer of your
son had been in out of prison since he
was about 15
and he was in his 20s by the time he
committed the murder and i said
is there an argument that that you
should look at it the other way around
and that is that whatever happened to
him in prison
didn't work and the prison system
actually chucked him out onto the
streets
a more violent person than when he went
in and to their credit
as i would see it they they did have
they were willing to reflect on that
even though they were massively still
grieving their son had been dead for a
couple of years and he and they had a
grandson he had a young son himself
um who's left fatherless by this by this
uh
a murder but they were prepared to take
a deep breath and say
i'm we're that we're listening to what
you're saying and may and and and if you
can get people like that so anne marie
coburn who's the mother of um martha
fernbach the 15 year old the girl who
died
she's a huge advocate for the
legalization and licensing of drugs
having lost her daughter to drugs that
were supplied on the streets
and i think if you're going to get
people to make the argument you're
probably and i hope i hope i've used
some of those voices in the book
um but if you're going to if you're
going to get people to make the argument
and you're going to get the public to
listen
i think possibly you need to have voices
from people like that people who
actually are the victims and
and i talked about david merritt um who
who jack merritt's father who prepared
to say
not in my son's name don't have longer
and longer sentences because it doesn't
work
and when you get victims families saying
that
then maybe the public will listen i
think you're right that's what i was
getting at earlier on when i said that
the
emotive response to
animals pigs being gassed in chambers
and you know that to me
drives home the philosophical position
that i understand underpins veganism
the same as this i need to everybody
needs to
genuinely believe in the stats
and in the um justification
from for the policy that you're putting
forward
but that's not what is going to deliver
the hammer blow that's not the nail in
the coffin the nail in the coffin
is the grieving mother that says
if x then why because people people
remember that
you know um and man i
chris uh like i said i think it's a a
oddly revolutionary book that i didn't
think would have come out of someone
whose job i mean is your job are you
putting yourself out of a job here
well i'd like to uh if you weren't
needed anymore is that
is that the end goal is this just an
early retirement plan
well i can tell you now and i've and
people have said to me you know oh you
support criminals because they're your
livelihood etc
well actually nothing would give me
greater joy than to retire from
being a criminal lawyer because there
weren't enough people being put through
the criminal justice system and we had a
much lower rate of crime
and we had a much safer and happier and
fairer and more humane society
i'm very lucky of course because i have
several other jobs for example writing
books and presenting tv programs and
and various other things so so i'd have
something else to go to but but i i'm
absolutely
you know um i would nothing would bring
me
greater happiness than to make myself
redundant
what a way to finish that's so good
look chris justice on trial is an
awesome read anyone that is thinking of
getting it it will be linked in the show
notes below
of course also you're you're pretty big
on twitter you're pretty putting out
some really interesting stuff what's
your twitter
it's at crim law uk um and you're right
i get involved in
quite a number of debates and and
different points but but i i also i'm
using
twitter as a way to try to make the
arguments and to and to persistently
bang the drum
and and it does get a lot of you know we
get a lot of people that
come many many people as the nature of
twitter
you know call me names and and tell me
everything i'm saying is insane
um but there are plenty of people who
are policymakers
mps uh who follow me on twitter who
comment favorably on what i say on
twitter
so my my sort of basic position is use
the voice that you've got we should
all be you you obviously have a platform
i've got slightly different platform in
different ways
uh and you've got to use the voice to
stand off what you believe in having
your chris because otherwise what's the
point of being
having freedom of speech if you don't
use it i couldn't agree more man you
want to
do something not be someone if you
become someone it's only because you've
done something
um we will have linked you fantastic
twitter justice on trial in the show
notes below
i'll also try and find if i can get a
shareable link to
uh crime are we tough enough on bbc
iplayer if not just you definitely can
you can get a link for that and you can
also um subscribe to my youtube channel
which is christopher qc and i put all
sorts on there including
career support for people who want to be
lawyers particularly who come from
backgrounds like mine of comprehensive
schools and
everything else we need to get more
people uh coming into the profession who
have kind of experienced every walk of
life and there's loads of guidance on
the youtube channel about that as well
i love it and then we can get the vlog
of me and you heading to russia to go
and see these
dark way hackers i mean and we drink a
lot of vodka as well i imagine whatever
you say man whatever you say look chris
thank you so much for your time and this
has been fantastic everyone that is
listening let me know what you think are
we gonna
are we gonna be able to reverse the um
the criminal justice system in the uk
is that have america got it as wrong as
chris says they do let me know
uh comments below or get at me you know
where to follow me at chriswell x
on all social media but chris thanks for
your time man
you're welcome thanks for the chat i
really enjoyed it
[Music]
you